et donc là on la carte cette assurés est
en train de créer son dossier médical
partagé ce carnet de santé numérique
existe depuis octobre 2018 dans les
yvelines
il permet de regrouper toutes les
données d'un patient comme les
pathologies les allergies éventuelles ou
l'historique des soins on évite de
refaire des examens qui aurait par
exemple déjà été fait ou au contraire on
a des résultats plus anciens donc on
sait qu'il faut agir peut-être refaire
un nouveau contrôle de tel ou tel examen
avantage de ce dossier médical partagé
pour les professionnels de santé un gain
de temps et une meilleure prise en
charge des patients la possibilité
d'avoir accès à un certain nombre de
données notamment des données
biologiques permet aux pharmaciens
d'adapter la posologie ou vérifier la
cohérence entre la posologie et les de
certains médicaments et les données
biologiques du patient notamment chez le
personnel ce jeu-là personnages et
quelques minutes suffisent pour créer
son dmp sur le site internet dans un
point d'accueil assurance maladie ou
bien en pharmacie toutes les données
sont confidentielles et sécurisé vous
garder totalement la main sur le contenu
de votre dossier médical partagé donc le
professionnel de santé pour accéder au
dossier médical a besoin de votre accord
et surtout de sa carte de professionnel
de santé
le stockage des données qui v qui est
assurée par un hébergeur extérieur qui a
été homologué par le ministère de la
santé
aujourd'hui dans les yvelines plus de 95
mille personnes ont couvert leur dossier
médical partagé